Speaker 1: Let's keep talking to people because
I don't know there are people who want to talk
and it seems like it's a great thing. Let's
go to Guilherme from Montreal. Guilherme,
I had a beautiful time there last week.
Speaker 3: Oh, hi, David. Well, glad to hear
you had a beautiful, beautiful time. You know,
what was the weather when you came over? I mean,
I did not go out all that much. I
was pretty much secluded at home.
Speaker 1: It was insanely hot, actually.
And you know what? I told this story or I'm
going to tell the story on today's bonus show.
I was recognized on the street more in Montreal
than anywhere else that I have ever been.
I was only there six days and 12 people
came up to me to say they watched the show.
Speaker 3: Nice. Nice. I mean, to be fair, most of
us use your show, The Young Turks and David Pakman
and The David Pakman Show and Cousins. My dad,
as a great way to stay informed on what's
happening all the way over there. Beautiful
country, USA. I think.
Speaker 1: That's
fantastic. Well, what was on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Well, first and foremost,
just pointing out that when I when we talked
last time, my friends really liked your idea of
trying to tackle campaign finance as a
constitutional amendment. Good. And my actual
big question right now is a lot more that it gets
a lot less hypothetical question of what do you
feel about calling the current era of politics
worldwide, not just in the U.S.? In an era of
what could I say? I'm looking for a word here.
Not. Oh, yeah. There you go. There we go. Glory
politics. So it's all about getting your name on
something. It's all about getting your name to be
recognized as the name that did something good.
Speaker 1: I don't think that that's unique to
this era. I mean, for me, there are other things
that strike me as unique to this era, including
the high percentage of people engaged in politics
who quite literally have no idea what's going on
and understand nothing about anything, like the
fact that that's a movement and it's a movement
that has pride. We don't know a damn thing about
anything and we vote and you've got to deal with
us. Ha ha. That is seems much more unique to this
era. You know, the glory politics stuff. If we
want bridges and and all these different things
named after us, I feel like that's been going on
at least since the fifties in the United States.
Speaker 3: I get what you get what you're getting
at, but I'm more thinking about before it's
been built. I want my name on it. I mean,
we all know that Obamacare was essentially
dubbed Obamacare after it was passed because
it was more convenient than saying Affordable
Care Act every single time you wanted to say it.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, I don't
think you're wrong that this exists.
It doesn't strike me as the most notable
thing about the era. I'll put it that way.
Speaker 3: No, that's perfectly
fine. Yeah. Oh, that lovely. Not
have a great day and thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Gail, real quick, are you a saint via
tour bagel guy or a fair amount bagel guy?
Speaker 3: That's a great question.
I'll have to say find at her. Wow.
Speaker 1: That's a big declaration from you.
Speaker 3: It's mostly because every
single time I have a bagel that's the most
available to me where I am.
Speaker 1: Oh, okay. So
it's a convenience thing and.
Speaker 3: I've never had a single
problem with it. So it's a recognizable
brand for me. It's a it's a literal.
I know this is good enough for me. I don't need
to go test further unless that's unavailable.
Speaker 1: Hey, if it ain't broke,
don't fix it. I like that game.
Speaker 3: I mean, don't get me wrong. If you if
you serve me any other bagel, I'll take it and
probably enjoy it just as much as. As long as it's
a decent quality. Just don't get don't get me to
try and choose another than that one.
Speaker 1: I'm with you. All right,
my friend. Thank you for the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you. And have a great day.
Speaker 1: All right. There
is Guillaume from Montreal.